Gut.
Weisst du, wer sie ist?
- Nein.
Das ist auch richtig. Du warst
noch gar nicht auf der Welt,
als ich schon auf der Welt war.
Du hast nichts verpasst.
Sie ist Olympiasiegerin im Skifahren.
- Ach, was?
Marie-Theres Nadig,
sagt dir das etwas?
Nein.
Dann gratuliere ich noch.
Jetzt kannst du bei YouTube
meinen Namen eingeben.
Dann siehst du vielleicht was.
- Ja.
Marie-Theres Nadig, der erste
weibliche Skistar der Schweiz.
Sie holt an den Olympischen Winter-
spielen 1972 in Sapporo zweimal Gold.
(Originalkommentar) Sie kommt ins
Ziel. Die Bestzeit ist 1:30:75.
Neue Bestzeit! Marie-Theres Nadig
in Führung mit 1:29:90.
Es ist der Beginn einer Zeit,
in der Skifahrer Helden werden
und jedes Kind in der Schweiz
Ski fährt.
Man will sein wie die Idole.
Auch ich gehöre zu dieser Generation.
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Doch wer von den Jungen kennt heute
Peter Müller oder Vreni Schneider?
(Originalkommentar)
Schön im Rhythmus gefahren.
Vreni Schneider
mit einer fantastischen Fahrt!
Was ist geblieben
vom Glanz der vergangenen Tage?
Wie war es damals, als alle
Ski fuhren, und was ist heute?
Sportgeschäft Nadig
in den Flumserbergen.
Ich bin bei Marie-Theres Nadig.
Früher hing sie
bei uns zu Hause als Poster.
Sie sei Maite, sagt sie mir,
Marie-Theres sei zu vornehm für sie.
Das ist wie früher.
Die Frau bügelt, der Mann zieht ab.
Seit ihrer Pensionierung hilft Maite
ihrem Bruder Thomas im Geschäft.
Am liebsten sei sie unten im Keller.
Wir zwei hatten es
immer gut zusammen.
Er musste mich früher
immer mitnehmen.
Zum Skifahren?
Ja, ich bin
drei Jahre jünger als er.
Ich sagte unserer Mutter jeweils,
dass ich auch gehen wolle,
dass ich auch
so schnell fahren wolle.
Er hatte nicht so Freude, aber ich
bin einfach hinterher gefahren.
Als jüngstes von fünf Kindern
wuchs Maite in den Flumserbergen auf.
Sie sei schon immer eine Drauf-
gängerin gewesen, sagt der Bruder.
Und der Liebling des Vaters.
Der Schnee lag ums Haus
und Skifahren war selbstverständlich.
Früher konnte man in den
Flumserbergen einfach Ski fahren.
Etwas anderes gab es nicht.
Wenn es morgens hell wurde, ging man
auf die Ski und kam abends heim.
Man fuhr den ganzen Tag auf und ab.
Man machte und tat, was man konnte.
Das war natürlich einfach
die Passion, die wir hatten.
Es war Freiheit. Wenn man mit
den Skiern einen Hang runterfuhr,
dann war das für mich Freiheit.
Niemand redete dazwischen.
Man hörte nichts, weil man ja fuhr.
Es war scheissegal,
was der andere sagte.
Machte man eine Kurve falsch,
war es egal.
Es war einfach passiert,
aber man hatte die Freiheit.
Maite sagt, sich messen mit anderen
habe ihr nichts bedeutet.
Sie habe nur draussen sein wollen.
* Rattern *
Ich war wild. Ich fuhr einfach Ski.
Ich erinnere mich an das erste Ren-
nen, an dem ich teilgenommen hatte,
Schweizer Meisterschaft der JO
im Hoch-Ybrig.
Dort war ein Mädchen,
das Angst hatte.
Ich sagte,
sie müsse keine Angst haben,
sie müsse einfach zwischen den Toren
durchfahren, das sei nicht schlimm.
1972 im japanischen Sapporo
dann die Überraschung:
Marie-Theres Nadig
holt zweimal Olympiagold.
Mit 17 Jahren.
Mich gab es damals noch nicht,
doch meine Eltern haben mir
von diesem Fernsehereignis erzählt.
(Mann) Die ist schnell!
Die ist viel zu schnell!
(Frau) Hopp, hopp!
- (Beide) Hopp, hopp!
Gewonnen!
* Jubel *
Die junge Maite Nadig
schlägt Favoritin Annemarie Pröll
aus Österreich
und beglückt die Schweiz.
(Originalkommentar)
Eine Woge der Begeisterung
geht durch den Schweizer
Blätterwald, durch das ganze Volk.
Ich habe nichts verstanden.
Ich dachte an der Pressekonferenz,
warum die so Blödsinn fragen.
Einer fragte, wie der Schnee war.
Ich antwortete: "Weiss."
Es sah ja jeder,
dass der Schnee weiss war
und dass das nichts Spezielles war.
Oder ich wurde gefragt,
warum ich die Schnellste war.
Ich antwortete:
"Weil die anderen langsamer waren."
Ich war nicht vorbereitet auf das.
Die Olympiadelegation wurde
von Volk und Bundesrat empfangen.
Viermal Gold
und zahlreiche Medaillen.
Die Spiele gingen
als die goldenen Tage von Sapporo
in die Geschichte ein.
* Dynamische Blasmusik:
"Sechseläutenmarsch" *
Maite wurde zum Medienstar
und tappte gleich in die Falle.
Vor laufender Kamera
kaute sie vor dem Bundesrat Kaugummi.
Das kam schlecht an.
* Dynamische Blasmusik:
"Sechseläutenmarsch" *
Ein Jahr später
machte das Schweizer Fernsehen
eine Homestory bei den Nadigs.
Das ist ein Schöner.
"Liebe Marie-Theres Nadig. Ich halte
Ihnen schon jetzt die Daumen
für das nächste Skirennen. Ich wohne
in einem Bergdorf und träume davon,
Sie einmal kennenzulernen. Können
Sie mir ein Autogramm schicken?"
Machst du das, bitte?
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Viel zu jung sei sie damals gewesen,
um zu begreifen,
was mit ihr geschehe,
sagt Marie-Theres Nadig heute.
Manchmal ist es ekelhaft.
Ich bin lieber daheim,
wo einen die Angehörigen kennen.
Aber es ist blöd.
Wenn man z.B. mit Freunden oder
Kollegen ins Restaurant geht,
kann man nicht mehr
so viel Blödsinn machen.
Sonst heisst es: "Ja, schau,
die Nadig, wie die sich aufführt!"
"Sie will wieder
die Grosse raushängen."
Wenn ich vieles mitgemacht
und mich selbst
in den Vordergrund gestellt hätte
und wenn ich nicht immer
meine Meinung so klar gesagt hätte,
hätte ich sicher
mehr daraus machen können.
Mein Pendant ist Bernhard Russi.
Der macht das hervorragend.
Aber ich möchte das ja nicht,
ich wollte das nicht.
Und ich kann es auch nicht.
Weil du zu direkt bist?
- Ja, weil ich nicht der Typ bin.
Ich hätte keine Lust dazu gehabt.
Ein Star wider Willen.
Das war mir so nicht bewusst.
Finanziell sei ihr Weg nicht immer
einfach gewesen, sagt Maite Nadig.
Denn aufs Geschäft
einer erfolgreichen Skirennfahrerin
habe in den Flumserbergen
niemand gewartet.
Ski- und Wintertouristen waren auch
damals, genauso wie heute, umkämpft.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Am Pistenrand,
ein paar Berge weiter südlich,
treffe ich die erfolgreichste
Schweizer Skifahrerin aller Zeiten:
Hoi zusammen!
Grüezi miteinander! Ist es gut?
Vreni Schneider.
Bis am Mittag!
Vreni Schneider - das ist für mich
Jugend in den 80er-Jahren.
Die Welt war in Ordnung
und Vreni Schneider siegte.
Doch diese Zeiten sind vorbei -
in jeder Hinsicht.
Es ist immer so ... Es gibt
doch noch Leute, die Ski fahren.
Es kommt halt auf die Eltern an,
ob sie es mit den Kindern lernen.
Wenn Schulklassen einen Skitag
haben, z.B. aus dem Unterland,
dann sind 80 % davon Schlittler.
Sie haben gar keine Ausrüstung mehr.
Und das ist natürlich schlecht
und schade.
Schlecht?
- Ja, sicher.
Gut, sie schlitteln.
Das ist ja auch Sport.
Immerhin: Dieses Jahr
gab es mal wieder richtig Schnee.
Das ist so. Jetzt könnte
immer so schönes Wetter sein,
denn wir haben bis in den Frühling
sicher genügend Schnee.
Vreni Schneider hat in Elm
eine Ski-, Snowboard- und Rennschule.
Geht es gut?
- Tipptopp.
Gut.
Gemeinsam mit ihrem Mann Marcel
managt sie den Betrieb.
Daheim in Elm als Skistar ein
Geschäft zu eröffnen, war schwierig.
Doch darüber will Vreni Schneider
nicht mit mir reden.
Es sei jetzt alles geregelt,
sagt sie.
Hallo, zusammen.
- Grüezi!
Hey, ihr seid super eingefahren.
Geniesst ihr es?
Ein Traumtag!
Kennst du sie?
Das musst du auch nicht.
Die sind viel zu jung.
Du kennst mich? Sicher?
Wer ist es?
- Vreni Schneider.
Sie war Skirennfahrerin.
Gewesen, ja.
Aber das ist schon lange, lange her.
Für ein Skilager
aus dem Kanton Zürich
organisiert die Skischule
Vreni Schneider ein Rennen.
21 am Start.
Alle aus dem Lager machen mit.
Aber Skirennen oder so
schaust du nicht? - Nein.
Warum nicht?
- Es ist langweilig.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenne Novak Djokovic.
* Lachen *
Also, Ski ist einfach ...
Ich mache das aus Spass.
Wegen der Mutter schaue ich Tennis.
Weil ja, wir sind Jugos und so.
Ja ...
Aber Ski fährst du nicht schlecht,
wenn du dieses J+S-Rennen fährst?
Ich hoffe,
ich fliege nicht auf die Fresse.
Ich kann es schon,
aber ich bin kein Profi.
Drei, zwei, eins, los!
Skilager - das gab es
während meiner Schulzeit jedes Jahr,
und dabei sein war Prestigesache.
Von dieser Oberstufenschule
aus Weiningen im Kanton Zürich
sind nur etwa 10 %
ins Lager gekommen.
(Frau) Solange wir Lehrer haben,
die es lässig finden und mitkommen,
bieten wir das an.
Ist es anstrengend?
Ja, man muss es sicher gerne machen.
Man muss sich bewusst sein,
dass man eine Woche lang
etwas weniger Schlaf kriegt,
als wenn man
eine Woche in die Ferien geht.
Wieso machen Sie es gerne?
- Es ist lässig,
wenn die Kinder die Chance haben,
auf die Piste zu gehen.
Viele Kinder gehen
nicht mehr auf die Piste.
So haben sie die Gelegenheit,
in den Schnee zu gehen
und ein Kulturgut der Schweiz
lernen zu können.
Kinder in der Schweiz sollen Ski
fahren. Das ist seit 100 Jahren so.
Gilt das immer noch?
Auch wenn Skigebiete
jedes Jahr um den Schnee bangen
und die Alternativen
günstiger und attraktiver sind?
Bei Vreni Schneider
werde ich nostalgisch.
Sie verkörpert den Höhepunkt
des Schweizer Skisports.
Damals gab es so viele,
die der Welt zeigen konnten,
was wir eben richtig gut können.
Wenn du in den 80er-Jahren
nicht gewonnen hast,
warst du nicht an einer WM.
Das war krass.
Wenn ich da
die Unterschiede zu heute anschaue,
dann sind sie heute
schnell mal an einer WM.
Wenn sie dazu
noch etwas Glück haben.
Gibt es einen oder zwei Verletzte,
dann sind sie mit Platz 15
an einer WM.
Und, ja ...
Das waren damals verrückte Zeiten.
Gold-Vreni, das war
in den 80er- und 90er-Jahren.
Sie hat fast alles gewonnen,
was es zu gewinnen gibt.
Doch da waren auch all die anderen:
Erika Hess, Pirmin Zurbriggen,
Peter Müller oder Maria Walliser.
Auf Hochglanzpapier
haben sich die Bilder eingeprägt.
Nie waren die Schweizer stärker als
an der Heim-WM in Crans-Montana 1987.
Es regnete Gold
und man fühlte sich unbesiegbar.
(Originalkommentar)
1:45:14, Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Jetzt Peter Müller.
Dass schliesslich ausgerechnet
der knorrige Peter Müller
gegen den eleganten Zurbriggen
in der Abfahrt gewann -
das war irgendwie cool.
(Originalkommentar)
... vor Pirmin Zurbriggen.
Das ist Peter Müller heute.
Hi.
Vor 25 Jahren hat Müller
mit dem Skirennsport aufgehört.
Er ist jetzt Besitzer
eines Skigeschäfts im Kanton Zug.
Allerdings sei das
mehr Hobby als Geschäft.
Schneie es den Leuten nicht auf den
Kopf, fahre niemand Ski, sagt er.
Okay, I will look this afternoon
and then you get ...
Bei Skirennen im Fernsehen hiess es
immer: "Peter Müller aus Adliswil."
Das sei lange vorbei, sagt er mir.
Er ist
aus seiner Heimatgemeinde weggezogen.
Adliswil habe ihm nach dem WM-Titel
vier Teller geschenkt.
Das fand er mickrig.
Seither lebt er in Baar.
Ehemalige Spitzensportler hätten
in der Schweiz einen schweren Stand,
sagt Müller, der mit Skifahren
richtig Geld gemacht hat.
Dort sind die fünf Medaillen, ja.
Das ist Weltrekord.
Fünf WM- und Olympia-Abfahrten
nacheinander,
der schlechteste Platz war Zweiter.
Viele Kinder haben Freude daran.
Ups ...
Da fällt gleich alles runter.
Der gelernte Gärtner hat nach der
Lehre auf die Karte Skiprofi gesetzt.
Der Vater habe das nie verstanden,
nur geduldet.
Sie sind nie gekommen,
um dir zuzuschauen?
Nie. Also,
mein Vater kam mal nach St. Moritz
und meine Mutter nach Wengen - und
dort hat es mich 1981 überschlagen.
Und ... und ...
... dann sagte sie,
sie komme nicht mehr.
Wenn sie komme, falle ich hin.
Das war schon hart, ja.
Klein Peter ging schon früh
mit dem Vater auf Skitour -
im Winter beinahe jedes Wochenende.
Durch einen Kollegen ist er zufällig
beim Skirennsport gelandet.
Er war auf Anhieb gut.
Er merkte, dass da etwas drinlag.
Müller blieb dran und
trainierte als Bub auf seine Weise -
oft allein.
Ich hatte 40 Stangen.
Die holte ich jedes Jahr
aus einem Bachbett.
Aus Haselnuss.
Ich schälte sie,
bemalte sie blau, rot und gelb
und steckte meinen Lauf aus -
meist im Tiefschnee,
denn auf der Piste durfte ich nicht.
Und dann raste ich
den ganzen Tag hoch und runter,
bis ich die 25 Läufe hatte,
also die 1'000 Tore.
Vorher ging ich nicht nach Hause.
Warum hast du das gemacht?
- Weil ich Erfolg haben wollte.
Ohne Fleiss kein Preis.
(Kommentator)
Hier kommt Peter Müller!
Mit 23 Jahren
kommt der erste grosse Erfolg:
Peter Müller gewinnt 1980
das Lauberhornrennen.
Nach sechs Jahren
endlich wieder ein Schweizer.
Ich kann mich erinnern, dass er immer
wieder Kommentare einstecken musste -
wie diesen
aus der Sendung "Karussell":
(Originalton) Müller hat nicht die
Ausstrahlung eines Bernhard Russi
oder den Walliser Charme
eines Roland Collombin.
Als Unterländer
hat er es sicher auch schwerer,
Fans zu mobilisieren,
als Fahrer aus richtigen Skiorten,
die dann fast dem Dorf oder
sogar einem ganzen Kanton gehören.
Peter Müller, der grantige Held.
Mir scheint,
er ist sich treu geblieben.
Sein Freund Emilio Stecher
kannte ihn früher nur vom Fernsehen.
Wir haben natürlich besonders
mit Pitsch mitgefiebert,
wie er als Flachländer
es den Berglern gezeigt hat.
Sie waren ein Fan von Peter Müller?
Natürlich.
- Wieso denn?
Ja, in den 80er-Jahren, wissen Sie,
da sass die Skination vor dem TV.
Mittags schaute man Skirennen.
Man rannte in der Pause
von der Schule nach Hause,
um Skirennen zu schauen.
Das war ein Nationalsport.
Wissen Sie, früher gab es
noch kein anderes Fernsehen.
Am Mittwoch um 17 Uhr
kam "Das Spielhaus",
und sonst lief das Testbild.
Nur wenn Skirennen liefen,
war Action am Fernseher.
Das hat man alles geschaut.
Ich bin nicht so jung,
dass ich das nicht mehr wüsste.
(Lachend)
Ich kann mich noch erinnern.
Peter Müller, der erfolgreichste
Schweizer Abfahrtsläufer,
blieb auch nach seinem Rücktritt
in den Medien präsent.
In der Schweiz gibt es keine Royals,
dafür Skistars.
Doch Müller meint, das sei
in der Schweiz nicht viel wert.
In Österreich sei das anders.
Nach seinem Rücktritt
lief es für ihn nicht immer rund -
weder beruflich noch privat.
Nein, hier ist verboten. Verbot!
Nein.
- Warum ist es verboten?
Ja, dort herrscht Unordnung.
- Unordnung.
Nein, da geht niemand rein,
sonst werde ich sauer.
Ich habe dort nicht aufgeräumt.
Was ist Ihr Job hier im Laden?
Mein Job im Laden? Hm ...
Ein bisschen helfen,
wenn ich Zeit habe ...
Sie muss die russischen
Kundinnen und Kunden betreuen.
Ah, ja, die russischen Kunden ...
- Möglichst viele Kleider verkaufen.
... sind ganz speziell.
Schatz, diese Brille ...
Die ehemalige Kunstturnerin Svetlana
ist Müllers zweite Frau.
Sie sagt,
mit ihm sei Sport nie Spass.
Peter wolle gewinnen. Immer noch.
Von den Skipisten
hat er sich verabschiedet.
Er fährt nur noch Tourenski.
Das andere habe er gehabt.
Das war eine geile Zeit.
Aber du geniesst sie fast zu wenig.
Du merkst erst,
wenn du aufgehört hast,
dass du ein Depp warst.
Da hast du gewonnen,
dort hast du gewonnen ...
Eigentlich kannst du es
gar nicht geniessen,
kannst gar nicht richtig feiern.
Wir sind wieder in Elm,
auf der Skipiste.
* Eingängiger Schlager: "Ich will
immer wieder dieses Fieber spür'n"
von Helene Fischer *
Da unten ist Florian, der Ältere,
der auf der Sportschule ist.
Ich gehe ihm Hallo sagen.
Die Sportschule Glarus trainiert.
Die beiden Buben von
Ex-Skirennfahrerin Vreni Schneider,
Flavio und Florian, stehen noch am
Anfang einer möglichen Skikarriere.
Willst du Rennfahrer werden?
Ja, mein Bruder
will das eigentlich auch.
Du willst auch Rennfahrer werden?
Wie viele aus einer solchen Gruppe
schaffen es? Wisst ihr das?
Vielleicht einer.
Aha, einer?
Ob es jemand aus dieser Gruppe
tatsächlich dereinst schaffen
und gar
Identifikationsfigur werden könnte?
Und?
- Ja, ja.
Der Schnee ist weich.
Er darf nicht zu stark drücken.
Sie müssen mit Gefühl fahren.
He, ist dir was passiert?
Nein, aber mir ist
dieses Teil abgefallen.
Geht's?
Du musst mit Gefühl fahren.
Druck geben, aber mit Gefühl fahren.
Ich weiss zwar nicht,
wie das geht ...
Oberhalb der Acht ist eine Banane,
da dreht es mich um.
Okay, wenn du es weisst, dann
kannst du ja früh genug drehen.
Ist gut?
- Ich fahre einfach.
Super. Gib ihm! Super, Flo.
Eigentlich sollte man es
nicht zu ernst nehmen,
und doch muss man ...
Wenn man den Aufwand schon betreibt,
muss es auch
professionell gemacht werden.
Dann muss das Training professionell
sein - und sie eben auch.
Ja, hier kommt Flavio.
Vreni Schneider weiss,
was man auf sich nimmt.
Hey! Geht's gut?
Ihre Knie sind vom Profisport kaputt.
Ja, da musst du
früh genug dran sein.
Super, Flavio! Bis später, ja?
Weiter so!
Für die Kinder ist es wichtig,
dass du sie motivierst.
Das ist ...
Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Damit sie motiviert sind
und Freude daran haben.
Dann fahren sie auch gut.
Ich muss mich hier abstützen.
Das ist halt die Mutter -
sie muss sich abstützen.
Und dann ist man eben froh, dass man
das nicht mehr selbst machen muss.
Beim Skisport ist es wohl
wie im richtigen Leben auch:
Es ist nicht alles Gold, was glänzt.
Und die Zeiten ändern sich.
Ich bin noch mal
in den Flumserbergen,
beim ersten weiblichen
Skistar der Schweiz, Maite Nadig.
Sie hat nie etwas anderes gemacht
als Skifahren.
Erst war sie Rennfahrerin,
dann Skitrainerin.
Was kommt in deinem Leben noch?
Das weiss ich nicht.
Wenn ich das wüsste!
Die Ski lasse ich ...
Ich habe genug.
Ich will nur noch für mich fahren.
Skifahren war nicht nur für dich?
Früher fuhr ich schon für mich. Und
ein bisschen auch für die Schweiz.
Das Schweizer Kreuz
trug man ja auch.
Wenn die Hymne gespielt wurde, lief
es mir immer kalt den Rücken runter.
Das ist auch jetzt noch so.
Ich bin halt ein Patriot,
ein Eidgenosse.
Eidgenossin.
Mach ich. Gut.